the whole defund the police hysteria was
a disaster for everyone involved a lot
of people
died because of it they got murdered
when the police retreated neighborhoods
got much more dangerous of course
but the other thing we learned was just
how deeply
hypocritical that people in charge are
there's really no depth to their
hypocrisy
we've got a new story tonight that tells
you
how deep it goes the story begins in
november 1st when a portland city
commissioner by the name of joanne
hardesty used the
lyft app to get a ride now in case
you're not familiar with joanne hardesty
she's the member of the portland
political class who made defunding the
police
her main mission she's called for 18
million dollars in
cuts to the portland police department
she says most calls for help
aren't real so with that in mind
here is a 9-1-1 call that joanne
hardesty made
during her lift ride just last week
9-1-1 what's your emergency uh well i
got a left
driver that decided he would just drop
me off at a filler station and he wants
me to get out
and i'm not getting out of the car and
the dog had a feeling station not
happening
all because i asked him to put the
window up but i'm not leaving
he says i have to get out of his car or
he's calling the police so i decided to
call for house
well she sounds like a lot of fun so
what's the emergency 911 what's your
emergency
well joanne hardisty's emergency was the
driver didn't want to roll the car's
windows up presumably because
kovit the police arrived and concluded
that no crime had been committed
it turns out even in portland it's not a
criminal offense to have your windows
open though maybe they'll make it one
so in response to all of this joanne
hardisty claims that she quote
proactively called the police because as
a woman of color
she was worried that officers would put
her in danger if someone called them
first
in other words we have to call the
police to protect us from the police
until we defund
the police there you go